quisiera preguntarle en primer lugar en
qué contexto se producen estos hechos de
hecho otras generan manifestaciones en
guadalupe previas a estos violentos
hechos contra el elevado costo de vida
en la región
buenas noches están ciegos y bueno hay
que saber que son dos departamentos
franceses desde
1949 es decir que en este momento la hay
una desconfianza fuerte pero que no es
nueva vimos muchas manifestación muchas
huelgas esos últimos años entonces esto
está enmarcado justamente en un fenómeno
que se está ya llevando desde hace años
la desconfianza de las élites francesas
del poder central giacominismo es decir
que el poder administrativo burócrata
por tecnócratas es lo que está
reprochando es decir que no ellos están
buscando más autonomía poder justamente
llevar a cabo a sus propias leyes y eso
es complicado frente a la mentalidad
descentralizada de francia entonces lo
que vemos es que este tema de la
ultraperiferia es decir que esta
continuidad territorial que quiere
imponer el gobierno central del hexágono
esto está rechazado desde hace varios
años desde en este momento la isla sufre
de varios problemas el primero problema
primero es un problema de desempleo un
problema de costo de vida que es más o
menos 12% más caro que en francia el
nivel de pobreza es dos veces superior
es decir que hay una desigualdad total
que se puede justamente sentir y no hay
lucha real en el tema de cómo será la
precariedad que conoce justamente es la
lista en el 2017 se trató de hacer una
ley pero el problema es que vimos que no
había resultado a los frutos se trató
justamente desde el hasta antes del 2009
empezar a trabajar sobre el tema de la
canasta familiar es decir qué tal poder
subsidiar ciertos tipos de productos
pero aquí nos dimos cuenta que no eran
productos tampoco que no compraban la
lista entonces no entendía cómo está
asociando productos que no eran los
productos de uso familiares entonces
esto es un poquito de este malestar
familiar como de malestar social que se
está llevando a cabo y el segundo
podemos ver que es el tema de justamente
desconfianza frente al estado por
diferentes razones del tema de la cómo
se llama del producto con cloro para
tratar las verdaderas que ha intoxicado
la mayoría de la isla y presentará una
denuncia de dos pistas por entrenamiento
que es un juicio dentro de poco va a
estar llevaba a cabo estaba el tema
también del tratamiento del azúcar en
las bebidas señoras mismas normas que en
la metropol y ahorita están viviendo
también el tema del área el sargazo creo
que es donde no vemos justamente a la
voluntad del centro de poder apoyar
perdón pero brevemente nos quedan
alrededor de 30 segundos pero no quiero
dejar de preguntarle teniendo en cuenta
lo que acaba de decir además cómo
evaluar la reacción del gobierno francés
que envió al refuerzo policial y cómo
cree que debería proceder
en este momento también hay un
afrontamiento político es decir que no
hay una vida que está isla ha agotado
por mayoría forma crone la la las
anteriores selecciones etc se pensaban
justamente tener más apoyo del gobierno
central y en este momento no están
teniendo es decir que es un poquito el
fenómeno que vimos con chalecos
amarillos en francia en donde es
contento y esto no apoya a la red social
con el fenómeno de burbuja es decir que
es una caja de resonancia que en este
momento está está llevando la gente a
poderse más y más bravos el gobierno
está un poquito asustado porque
últimamente la aduana se han robado las
municiones y armas es por eso que
mandamos justamente el dirigente de red
y la policía